look at this problem three added to a
number gives us ten find that number we
know it's seven but that's not the
reason why I asked you this question I
want to know how can we represent this
problem in a simpler way we can probably
say X plus three equals ten find X 3 is
added to a number to get 10 we just
assign a variable to that number this is
called an equation and it helps us write
large problems like these in a shorter
way this equation has just one variable
which is X and it's an unknown and the
highest power of X is 1 these kinds of
equations are called linear equations in
one variable they are also referred to
as first degree equations in one
variable they are called linear of first
degree because the highest degree of the
variable is 1 we will have a deeper
understanding of why such equations are
called linear in the coming videos we
categorize an equation into three parts
we have an equality sign in the center
to its left is the left-hand side which
is shown here as LHS and to its right is
the right-hand side shown here as RHS
the problems for such kind of equations
require us to solve for the value of the
variable there are two ways in which we
can solve the equation the first method
is called the inverse operations method
and the second one is by using the
transpose method both the methods give
us the same answer but after we solve
equations using both the methods we will
realize that the transpose method is
preferred over the inverse operations
method
you
you